love being outside like this
in just one year beth's life has been
completely
transformed beth is amazing
beth is so happy beth is beth is
supported
she's finally able to do things that 19
year olds can she's dying her hair she's
experimenting with makeup she's
she's finding out who she is she's she's
so happy
12 months ago beth who is autistic spent
24 hours a day
locked up in a cell with little human
contact
jeremy described his daughter's
treatment as inhumane
my daughter is not an animal after the
scandal of beth's treatment was exposed
the health secretary matt hancock
promised to have her released
by christmas after i met you
things got worse they actually wanted
beth to to go into a high secure
facility
we managed to get autistic people in who
are experts in reviewing
situations like beth beth now lives in
an open plan unit
with bespoke care designed to manage her
sensory needs
it also means she's free to explore the
outdoors
to reconnect with nature and to enjoy
new hobbies
like fishing the right people in the
right place the right environment
supporting her in the right way it's not
difficult
beth has been held in institutions since
she was just
15. jeremy thought he might never see
his daughter free again i'd given up i
thought beth was going to be locked away
forever and you start to think what
what will my life be going forwards beth
missed out
so much you know that the growing up
processes the
the building relationships the having
friendships
those are skills she doesn't yet have
beth doesn't feel quite ready to speak
to us
herself but has asked her father
to pass on a message it chokes me every
time
i think about it and that message is
that
this has happened because people moved
into my world
they stopped trying to drag me into
theirs
that's beth that's autism hundreds of
young autistic adults remain
trapped in the system but beth's story
proves
there is another way and that they too
can be helped
to live rich rewarding lives
just like beth love you babe
ashish joshi sky news